يمكن لك ان تتخيلي المشهد حتى هذه اللحظه
بهذه الصور المباشره التي نحن الان من
خلالها نعكس هذا الواقع الاليم
الاف من المتطوعين الذين جاءوا من كل
المحافظات لاجل تقديم المساعده لاها لهذه
المدينه التي باتت على الارض الالاف من
الابنيه وعشرات الالاف من الشقق هي غير
صالحه بتا او اطلاقا للسكن فيها تخيلي ان
مدينه برمتها يبيتون اهلها في العراء وفي
المخيمات التي نصبت في الامكنه والتي نصبت
ايضا في الساحات والباحات الخارجيه خوفا
من الارتدادات اذا اخذنا ايضا هذه الصوره
التي كان قد سبق ان تكون في الايام
الماضيه مركزا تجاريا في المدينه كيف هي
الان اكوام من الاسمنت مع الحجاره مع كتل
الخشب مع الحاجات مع الدفاتر التي تخرج من
تحت الالقاب مع الثياب مع الاساس مع كل ما
هو يستعمل انسانيا او يتخيله الانسان اصبح
مجبولا وواقعا على الارض هلا محله هاته
الصور المؤلمه
الجرافات الشاحنات الالات الثقيله
الحفارات التي تقوم برفع على انقاذ الان
كما نشاهد